catherine travaille depuis 35 ans comme
employée de mairie à chalon si elles
manifestent aujourd'hui ce n'est pas à
cause de la hausse des prix du carburant
mais pour exprimer un ras-le-bol général
jusqu'à maintenant avant qu'il y avait
des grèves sont les premiers greffe
perdait de l'argent
donc j'ai dit le jour je le ferai je me
voudrait où tout le monde se mettra en
forme comme le 17 à 54 ans elle vit
seule dans un deux pièces qu'elle paye
400 euros par mois avec le prix de
l'électricité le gaz ou des impôts qui
ne font qu'augmenter dit elle elle ne
s'en sort pas moi à la fin du mois et
bien franchement s'il y avait pas moins
verrerie leur époque voilà tout seul je
pourrais pas y arriver alors elle a
enfilé son gilet jaune ce matin et
bloquent depuis 7h30 le pont de
bourgogne
l'axé principal pour traverser la saône
en espérant être entendus par emmanuel
macron bas j'espère qu'il va faire qu'on
va mener comment faire des concessions
il veut pas en faire mais ils feraient
mieux de se payer parce que on lâche
rapporte cette façon quitte à aller sur
le temps on se relaiera mais on ne
lâchera pas et on lâche rien rien rien
rien pour acquis fli celui là non non
mais j'ai vraiment la haine à une colère
contre contrôle dit oui contre lui parce
qu'en plus ils se noient chaque fois
qu'il parle non ça peut plus continuer
c'est pour ça que moi je pense que ça à
faire n'est pas tous à son ca va
continuer dans le temps et puis sinon
cela remet va me fois nous à sa fin et
68 catherine comme les gilet jaune que
nous avons rencontrés tout au long de la
journée sont dans leur grande majorité
tous prêts à renouveler leurs actions
demande s'il le faut